[Musique]
bonsoir à vis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de 7,8 échos tout de
suite le sommaire le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines mais aussi certaines
entreprises bénéficient de financements
européens objectif booster leur
développement
comment fonctionne-t-il comment les
mobiliser stéphanie von euw vice
président de la région ile de france en
charge des affaires européennes nous en
dira plus dans le cadre de la première
édition du paris saclay spring focus sur
le projet de ville connectée imaginé par
bouygues énergie et services une
plateforme permet de mieux gérer tous
les équipements d'une ville tout en
faisant des économies
de nouveaux locaux à guyancourt pour
l'entrepris socotec ou encore la bonne
santé du groupe emitech à montigny le
bretonneux
nous ferons également un tour d'horizon
de l'actualité économique dans notre
département
mais avant de développer tous ces titres
commençons avec un chiffre à 540
millions d'euros
il s'agit des fonds européens attribués
à la région ile de france pour la
période 2014 2020
c'est la région qui est chargée de gérer
cette enveloppe ces fonds sont destinés
aux entreprises aux associations ou
encore aux collectivités territoriales
on en parle en détail dans quelques
minutes puisque c'est le dossier de ce
numéro
à quoi pourrait ressembler la ville de
demain il ya quelques jours dans le
cadre de la première édition de paris
saclay spring la société bouygues
énergie et services a présenté un projet
smart cities reportage
cette maquette futuriste présentant les
équipements d'une ville connectée sera
très prochainement une réalité à
guyancourt bouygues énergie et services
a développé un hyperviseur urbain
objectif mieux gérer tous les
équipements d'une ville tout se passe
dans ce cockpit
on a développé donc une plateforme à
capgemini qui permet donc à distance de
pouvoir activer piloter des équipements
dont vous vous donner un exemple si on a
un accident de la circulation
il va falloir passer les feux
clignotants dans la ville il va falloir
rallumer l'éclairage falloir baisser les
bornes
donc tout ça on va pouvoir le faire
depuis un seul outil et de façon très
synchronisée en très peu de temps dans
les prochains mois dijon métropole sera
la première à expérimenter cette ville
du futur
d'autres agglomérations seraient
également intéressés saint quentin en
yvelines compte bien devenir dans un
avenir proche une smart city bien
évidemment on est tout à fait partant
pour travailler sur des expérimentations
et surtout tout ce qui est équipements
connectés pour faciliter la vie des
citoyens pour ce projet imaginé par
bouygues énergie et services compter une
enveloppe d'un peu plus de 100 millions
d'euros
cela comprend l'installation de
l'hyperviseur urbain mais aussi la
maintenance des équipements pendant 12
ans faux sur toi notez les économies
qu'ils vont avoir à côté donc on est sûr
à 15 millions d'économies sur la facture
énergétique
et puis on est encore sur plein d'autres
économies la maintenance les équipements
qui est divisé par deux des métropoles
plus intelligente mais aussi plus
durable voilà le pari de bruille énergie
services afin de faciliter le quotidien
des citoyens de demain ouvre à présent
le dossier de ce numéro consacré aux
financements européens le mois dernier
était consacré à l'europe
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
entreprises de 50 ans navy qui ont
sollicité les fonds européens pour se
développer
reportage les images sont signées
nicolas kirillovitch favoriser
l'émergence et le développement des
entreprises saint-quentinoise voilà
l'ambition du ski cube créé il ya un peu
plus d'un an
l'incubateur située à guyancourt a
permis en 2010 est la concrétisation de
270 création et reprise d'entreprise
un accompagnement possible grâce
notamment aux fonds européens
le ski cub a bénéficié d'une subvention
de 333 1659 euros profité de l'europe
pour se développer
c'est aussi le
à de l'entreprise émules sarr basée à
montigny le bretonneux elle est
spécialisée dans la conception
d'ingrédients innovant sous forme
d'émission un projet phare dans le
domaine de la nutrition clinique que
nous souhaitions développer par
nous-mêmes mais avec un manque de moyens
nous a donné l'idée et l envie d'aller
chercher des fonds européens pour
pouvoir justement nous aider à financer
le développement l'industrialisation et
la commercialisation de de ce projet en
propre avec m charge alors on a démarré
le projet en 2015
on a commencé à monter le monter le
dossier et obtenu donc la réponse et les
fonds en 2007 ont commencé réellement le
travail sur le projet en 2016 est donc
maintenant jusqu'en jusqu'en 2019 avec
une enveloppe d'un peu plus d'un but 7
millions d'euros pour faire une demande
de fonds européens certaines entreprises
se tournent vers des sociétés de conseil
à magny les hameaux cap industrie fait
partie du cluster gennari ce groupe
parmi ses activités le montage de
dossiers de financement européen
ce que l'on fait c'est con
on va rechercher des projets enfin ou
des entités qui sont à la recherche de
fonds à la fois publics mais aussi
privés et donc on va mettre en
adéquation enfin voilà leur faire leur
permettre de gagner un peu de temps et
donc nous on est là juste pour apporter
la valeur ajoutée c'est-à-dire corrigé
les dossiers les mettre en oeuvre la
s'assurer qu'ils sont bien monter quand
des entreprises qui parfois se
découragent face à la complexité des
dossiers et pourtant elles ont tout à y
gagner
justement les français sont un peu mal
placé là dessus on est peu demandeur de
le faire aller fond c'est pas une perte
de temps puisque on peut s'en servir
pour d'autres
notre recherche de financement donc non
c'est pas difficile ça demande du temps
sa demande de l'investissement sa
demande
de 10 mètres un peu de passion mais
voilà c'est le métier des entrepreneurs
froid pour la période 2014 2020 la
région ile de france dispose d'une
enveloppe de 540 millions d'euros de
fonds européens
elle vient tout juste de lancer un appel
à projets autour des programme agri
orban elle vous l'avez peut-être aperçu
sur ces images la vice présidente de la
région ile de france en charge des
affaires européennes
stéphanie von euw était en visite au ski
cube à guyancourt
nous l'avons rencontré pour en savoir
plus sur la gestion de ces fonds
européens
stéphanie von euw bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes vice président de la région ile de
france en charge des affaires
européennes alors nous trouvons aux
cuves le ski qfc l'incubateur de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a bénéficié
justement d'une subvention européenne un
peu plus de 330 3000 euros alors quel
est le rôle de la région ile de france
justement autour de ces subventions
européennes alors la région alors c'est
souvent mal connu d'ailleurs mais un
rôle absolument essentiel en ce qui
concerne les fonds européens puisque
c'est tout simplement elle qui les gère
en réalité
les fonds européens ça relève de la
politique d'aménagement du territoire de
l'union européenne qu'on appelle
politique de cohésion et cette politique
elle a été régionalisée il ya quelques
années de ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la commission européenne
délègue aux régions donc à toutes les
régions françaises c'est pas simplement
l'île de france sur une programmation de
6 ans donc là c'est une programmation
qui va de 2014 à 2020 donc la région ile
de france dispose d'une enveloppe par
exemple de 540 millions d'euros et notre
boulot c'est des dépenses et au monde
job c'est de faire en sorte d'identifier
des projets qui pourront être financées
sur sur fonds européens et c'est la
région qui décide qui va en bénéficier
qui fait l'instruction des dossiers
donc c'est une politique qui est très en
réalité de proximité contrairement à ce
qu'on pense c'est pas du tout faux pas
du tout aller chercher les fonds
européens à bruxelles
on les a déjà en fête or vous le disais
sont mal connues ces fonds européens en
fait on a l'impression qu'ils sont pas
assez mobilisés est ce que c'est vrai
c'est malheureusement pas une impression
lors de la mandature précédente et de la
programmation précédente
ça fait presque mal du mal de le dire
mais la région ile de france a rendu 70
millions d'euros
faute d'avoir été en capacité de mettre
les projets qui pouvaient y répondre
donc ça c'est juste pas acceptable ce
n'est pas possible
pourquoi on est on a été
on a connu cette situation je pense deux
raisons la première c'est que
malheureusement en france on parle pas
d'europe où on parle mal d'europe
or souvent on peut avoir un discours
très pédagogue très concret obligé de
rentrer dans les grandes problématiques
institutionnelles mais pour dire voilà
ce que l'union européenne met à la
disposition des entreprises des
collectivités locales ou des
associations parce que ce sont elles qui
peuvent bénéficier des fonds européens
donc c'est en parler davantage
et puis ensuite c'est faire en sorte que
au niveau de la région on est les
équipes qui permettent de tourner dans
les territoires pour faire connaître ses
outils et ses dispositifs et je suis
sincèrement convaincu que selon l'adage
quand on veut on peut
puisque quand nous sommes arrivés début
2016 alors que la programmation avait
commencé déjà depuis plus de deux ans il
y avait seulement 4 % de l' enveloppe
qui était consommée nous sommes dit un
peu plus 18 mois après a maintenant 50 2
% de consommation
il ya plusieurs thématiques quelles
sont-elles tt m alors vous avez un
certain nombre de thématiques qui tourne
autour de 5,5 à 7 ça dépend comment
comment les comptes mais globalement les
grandes orientations c'est quoi c'est
tous les projets qui relèvent de
l'innovation et de la recherche ce sont
tous les projets qui relèvent de la
formation professionnelle et de
l'insertion dans l'emploi
ce sont tous les projets qui relèvent de
la création d'entreprise
ce sont les projets qui relèvent du
décrochage scolaire
et puis enfin qui permet de lutter
contre le décrochage scolaire et puis
ensuite vous avez deux thématiques
faisons on va dire environnementale qui
est une thématique sur tout ce qui est
la réhabilitation réhabilitation
énergétique et puis tout ce qui relève
de la transition également énergétique
et écologique
quand on fait une demande de fonder une
réponse à peu près
combien de temps alors on fonctionne par
appel à projet c'est à dire que c'est la
région ile-de-france qui lancent des
appels à projets sur les thématiques
vous avez entre 3 et 6 mois pour
manifester votre intérêt n'avait pas
déposé le dossier tout de suite parce
qu'une fois que vous avez manifesté
votre intérêt les équipes de la région
viennent vous voir et c'est là où c'est
j'espère qu'on est performant c'est vous
avez même les équipes qui vous aident à
monter le dossier
vous avez l'un des ateliers d'écriture
on monte le dossier avec vous et ensuite
il ya un délai d'instruction qui tourne
autour de 6 mois ça reste six mois mais
c'est beaucoup d'argent
question pratique on peut retrouver
toutes les informations j'imagine sur le
site internet
de la région ile-de-france avant qui
m'échappe voilà vous avez bien travaillé
c'est bien et on vous il est assez
interactif on vous invite vraiment s'il
ya des questions à les poser à demander
à ce qu'on vous rappelle et dans des
délais que je souhaite extrêmement bref
si ce n'est pas le cas j'invite voter
les téléspectateurs de le faire savoir
s'il n'était pas contacté assez
rapidement le faire savoir parce que
vraiment seul objectif qu'il y ait une
vraie interaction est une vraie
réactivité de la région sur ses demandes
merci stéphanie 29 des princes est
revenu pour le site i teco je rappelle
que vous êtes là vice président de la
région ile de france en charge des
affaires européennes et tout de suite on
passe à l'actualité économique en bref
avec notamment l'entreprise socotec qui
vient d'emménager dans de nouveaux
locaux
implantée à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis près de 40 ans le groupe socotec
et vient tout juste de prendre
possession de ses nouveaux locaux à
guyancourt spécialiste européen de
l'inspection et de la certification dans
la construction et les infrastructures
la société affiche un chiffre d'affaires
de 700 millions d'euros
les espaces que nous occupions était et
est devenu extrêmement obsolète
donc vous avez 450 personnes qui
travaillent ici donc il ya vraiment un
enjeu de d'avoir un espace de travail
beaucoup plus ouverts en plateau
permettant de la collaboration du
travail en équipe
et puis un autre enjeu qui est important
c'est que ce côté quai dans une
transformation
en france en particulier importantes ont
fait bouger beaucoup beaucoup de choses
dans notre façon de travailler d'autres
organisations dans une manière de nous
adresser à nos clients et le siège doit
aussi incarner cette transformation ce
changement nouvelle machine ou encore
bureaux administratifs 9 à montigny le
bretonneux l'entreprise emitech
spécialisée dans les tests de produits
avant leur commercialisation a investit
cette année plus de 7 millions d'euros
un exemple qui illustre parfaitement la
reprise des investissements à saint
quentin en yvelines
ils étaient plus de 600 participants
jeudi 31 mai pour l'édition 2018 du
trophée des entreprises à saint quentin
en yvelines
gros succès pour cette course destinée
aux acteurs économiques et
administratives du territoire
nouveauté cette année une épreuve de
golf
clin d'oeil à la ryder cup qui approche
à grands pas
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve mardi 19
juin pour un nouveau 7 8 et qu à très
bientôt
[Musique]